ja das ist in letzter zeit etwas öfter
passiert am wochenende ganz besonders
ich habe mit dem schlimmsten gerechnet
was da passiert das hat uns glaube ich
ein erstes erst mal hören und sehen
vergangen was ich einfach sehr sehr
schade finde nach diesem nach diesen
krachenden verlusten die bilder zu
verzeichnen haben sollten wir eigentlich
alles daran setzen und jetzt ersten zu
sortieren 42 den themen zu setzen und
uns beim programmatisch und personell
neu aufzustellen es wurde von der ersten
minute an gesagt schlag 20 uhr am
sonntagabend aber was passiert denn was
sehen wir denn es geht um posten es geht
um pöstchen es geht darum zu gucken dass
man irgendwie sehr leute versorgt den
kopf noch aus der schlinge ziehe ich
glaube das wird doch nichts ja ich würde
schon sagen das ist ein eindruck den du
nicht nur als cdu-mitglied hast sondern
den im moment viele haben gitta
connemann hat das gestern in einer
fraktionssitzung der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende ein bisschen auf
den punkt gebracht im politischen berlin
wird diskutiert über posten und an der
basis gibt es eine andere lebensrealität
da haben wir die schlimmste niederlage
bei uns im osten ja übrigens ganz
besonders und ich glaube deswegen müssen
wir jetzt auch sehen und ja stimme ich
zu es geht schon darum dass wir jetzt
nicht nur den eindruck erwecken hier
geht es darum ob jetzt minister xyz
dienstwagen behält sondern am ende muss
es darum gehen was ist eigentlich der
inhaltliche unterschied und das ist uns
muss man auch in der analyse sagen im
wahlkampf oft nicht gut genug gelungen
da haben wir oft dann vor rot-rot-grün
gewarnt auf den letzten metern aber
inhaltlich akzentuiert was dann ja
wasser komplett gefehlt hat die ist
dieses diese nach aktiv was du bei der
spd gesehen was auch bei den grünen
gesehen hast einfach zu wissen wofür
steht jemand was wähle ich und was
bekomme ich wenn nicht jemand trotzdem
mache genau das gleiche was so erlebt
hast dass die leute gesagt haben ich tue
mir tut das sehr sehr leid als
christdemokrat in aber wenn dann die
leute kommen sagen ich werde euch aber
nicht weil ich von euch überzeugt bin
sondern weil ich keine lust auf rot grün
habe das tut dir erstmal das tut ein
erster aber bei dir ist ja nicht nur die
wahlanalyse die dich aufregt sondern das
was jetzt passiert richtig also das
sozusagen die leute weiter auf ihren
posten bleiben philipp antrag ist an der
bürger fraktionssitzung wieso habt denn
da niemand mehr auf den tisch gehauen
und hat gesagt es reicht jetzt mal armin
g
dass ich auf jeden fall erstmal gut fand
war dass wir gestern so wie es mancher
ja vorher gesagt hat nicht diesen
personaldiskussionen hatte nicht einmal
offen gesprochen hätte ja auch passieren
können wir machen jetzt jeder
kandidieren werden leicht gewesen wäre
da einfach mal andere ich meine wie
können sie da reiht brinkhaus weiterhin
stellen ich meine ralph brinkhaus naja
eben jetzt sechs monate zu geben wo er
weiß dass er keine chance hat danach
nach zu bleiben das entscheiden toter
ist das unter sitzt er jetzt alle ihre
jungstars angst hat nein also ich finde
erst mal richtig dass wir eins und das
ist so habe ich das gestern auch
verstanden dass wir sagen die frage
oppositionsführer die wird noch mal
später verhandelt weil jetzt müssen wir
alles daraufsetzen regieren oder nicht
im dienst waren behalten habe ich über
halten und wie nachlaufen danach
überhaupt nicht darum geht es auch nicht
und ich habe immer gesagt und das ist
auch meine überzeugung regieren ist kein
selbstzweck und am ende ob regieren oder
oppositionen entscheidend ist die frage
gibt es ein weiterso oder gibt es
tatsächlich erneuerung und diese
erneuerung verbindet sich nicht nur mit
der frage wer sitzt auf welcher position
sondern haben wir auch irgendwie ein
kampfgeist und wollen wir politische
unterscheidbar kann sich ändern wenn wir
jetzt gehe ich oft und das ist ja auch
so eine frage wie geht man mit so einer
niederlage um jetzt tal der tränen und
jammern und lust auf opposition oder
sagen noch beginnen jetzt nicht auf
sondern aber irgendwie kampfesgeist ich
glaube jedenfalls durch ein jammer
haltung wurde eine jetzt gar keiner
überzeugen sondern sagen alle ja die
haben das völlig zurecht jetzt hier
nicht gewählt gelernt ein wenig tragbar
zu gehören displays ist wie man sich das
ladies first allgemein philipp ich habe
letzte woche ich hoffe wir können uns
tun die ja klar denn der union mit dem
sie jetzt ich habe letzte woche in witz
gemacht auf deinen kosten in der unia
häufig eher wahr gemacht und ja ich
deswegen wiederhole ich ihn auch jetzt
in der uni ich habe gesagt das problem
der union ist dass sie nicht sex ihres
anzubieten haben als philipp
praxislabors bei respekt habe ich gesagt
du wirst ja auch jetzt nicht als der
jüngste ich finde du bist ich würde uns
auch mal älter das ist auch jetzt nicht
schlimm meint aber warum ist das so
warum wirkt er nicht sexy ich finde auch
wirklich dass die union nicht sexy da
ist doch keiner mitleiden fall oder
sollen also war also bin ich damit
gehören wir haben natürlich
würde überkam mich also ein bisschen
moment muss man die karoo mehr ins
rampenlicht stellen aber kann man reich
so häufiger an wir machen
wir haben mit lieb gewinnt auch den
anfang also dieses jahr mit wie hat mir
ausschnitt und meine was mit dem
rampenlicht mit bekommt wer in den
talkshows sitzt und was man nach außen
hin mitbekommt dass bis dann zu wenig
tun zu viele andere ich meine die grünen
haben es geschafft sie haben sechs siege
wirkt auf viele haben wir die wahl
trotzdem nicht gewonnen roger köppel
also sex in ist ist das wirklich so ein
wichtiger vorhaben verdoppeln also den
robert habeck ist jetzt der große held
oder was
nein wenn du so verzweifelt bis das
partei dass du dich quasi in die
sexyness will die sägerei ist das letzte
ist
da bist du dich verloren als partei eine
wenn man die analyse macht so cdu da
muss man mal einen namen nennen der viel
zu wenig genannt wird nämlich entweder
den makler rallye mexiko
diesen
destabilisiere wenn du solche
parteifreunde aus brauchst du wirklich
keine vereinte mir diese loyalität mit
darf man aufgearbeitet werden zweitens
wenn die stadt das süße gift der macht
das süße gift macht die cdu war es so
lange drum und außen betrachtung und die
haben sich einfach auch etwas
korrigieren lassen von diesen ganzen
macht von dieser macht teilen haben und
haben eigentlich vergessen wer sie sind
und deshalb habe ich ja auch schon mal
gesagt die müssen im prinzip in der
opposition jetzt wieder herausfinden wer
sie sind was sie programm ist und wie
man hier mit einer neuen schwung rein
kommt erläutert ich bin ja nicht der
einer der darin jetzt total kritisiert
das steht mir nicht zu ich finde es
wichtig dass er jetzt nicht einfach dem
bett leben wird und sagt es gibt ihn
noch eine perspektive die spielregeln
sind ich trete die koalition hin bringt
aber insgesamt muss man sagen vermutlich
werde die opposition verdient und
vielleicht auch gesünder versichert
glaube nicht dass wir es schaffen eine
position ich habe da wirklich zweifel
gehört dass immer wieder in opposition
habermann seit jahren als die reha
zwei jahren erholt sich seit 1949 in
position bringt auch nichts die frage
ist ob man bei der opposition operation
nicht als automatismus bringt ja nicht
sondern die frage ist wo position oder
regierung was du brauchst ist den willen
zu sagen anzuerkennen wir haben eine
klatsche bekommen wir haben die wahl
verloren wir müssen was ändern und das
geht in der regierung oder in der
opposition und deswegen ist das ist
aktiven auf die frage oder versteifen
auf die frage ob regierung oder
opposition ist doch nicht finden weil
wenn man sagt man macht opposition und
alles bleibt wie es ist aber jetzt bei
einem respekt vor der macht gier der cdu
weiter im kanzleramt zu bleiben muss war
übrigens auch besser für das land
dabei hatte einen der vielleicht
muss man ja auch mal ein bisschen
darüber sprechen wer am ende mehr
prozent hat also an den laschen hat es
ja dann heute tatsächlich geschafft doch
noch dem wahlsieger zu gratulieren
nachdem wenige stunden zuvor angela
merkel das getan hat also das sind ja
auch dinge wo man sich denken was
passiert eigentlich im adenauer-haus ich
das ist da los' ich würde sagen so
richtig hat man die wahl dann gewonnen
wenn gegen einen keine regierung
gebildet werden kann gegen uns kann der
regierung amin laschet ist es gibt kein
haupt wahlsieger hat er gesagt werden
können liegt das wort noch mal erklärt
ja es ist das gegen uns kann keine
regierung gebildet werden und gegen
scholz gegen uns kann eine regierung
gebildet werden und gegen saubere waren
auf einer der hauptpunkte wahlsieger ein
haupt wahlsieger war zb angela merkel
würde ich sagen in den vergangenen
wahlen wogegen sie keine regierung
gebildet werden konnte das war unser
ziel auch diesmal haben wir nicht
erreicht
[Musik]